i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
[Música]
hace 34 años que trabajo en el área de
recursos humanos de empresas que se
dedican a la alta tecnología pero yo
siento que nunca trabaje
no porque no me haya esforzado o no haya
tenido que trabajar largas horas o no
haya enfrentado situaciones difíciles
pero amo lo que hago
y entonces nunca me costó empezar un día
de trabajo y terminar un fin de semana
soy de las personas afortunadas que
descubrieron tempranamente su propósito
pero hoy viene a plantearles la idea que
yo tengo sobre el futuro del trabajo
y últimamente seguramente ustedes hacen
lo mismo antes de dar una charla dar un
curso preparar un vídeo lo primero que
hago es buscar en google a ver qué es lo
que se está hablando ahí sobre el tema
que tengo que dar
y lo que encontré me sorprendió bastante
me hizo pensar que tal vez los años en
que la gente era feliz en el trabajo se
estaban acabando o peor que eso que tal
vez no habría futuro en el trabajo
inclusive encontré alguna página donde
uno podía poner su profesión o su
trabajo actual y te dice las
probabilidades que tenés de que tu
trabajo sea reemplazado por un robot
hablando de robots me acordé que cuando
yo era chica y vivía en el campo mira
una serie de dibujitos animados los
supersónicos
este en el que el futuro parecía algo
muy positivo y progresista
había autos voladores
había videoconferencias incluso podías
hacer videoconferencias con los médicos
si necesitabas hacer un diagnóstico
médico tragaba es una pequeña cámara y
el diagnóstico era certero inmediato
había televisores planos había relojes
inteligentes había cintas
transportadoras para hacer la vida más
fácil había un robot para hacer las
tareas del hogar cuidar a los niños
jugar con ellos había una casa
inteligente que preparaba la comida e
incluso despertaba al que no se quería
levantar a la mañana
me recuerdo fascinada en la década del
70 en un televisor blanco y negro con
una imagen inestable y de mala calidad
por una antena mirando este futuro
positivo y progresista
imagínense que aún hoy a uno le cuesta
pensar que esta serie de dibujitos
animados fue pensada en el año 62
pero mi infancia les diría que fue
mayormente impactada por visiones
negativas sobre el futuro había muchos
miedos en esos años
eran los años de la crisis del petróleo
de repente crisis política internacional
el precio del petróleo se había ido por
las nubes había mucha preocupación sobre
eso también
se hablaba de que venía la tercera
guerra mundial y era más grave porque
iba a ser nuclear esta vez y encima
cualquiera podía apretar un botón pues
el mundo desaparecería
otras cosas que recuerdo con espanto fue
saber que la producción de las de
alimentos que tenía el mundo no sería
suficiente para el crecimiento
demográfico de la población
saben qué
al final vi también que estas
previsiones negativas sobre el futuro
este futuro catastrófico responde a un
pensamiento lineal y secuencial que
considera que no va a haber ni
innovaciones ni disrupciones
pero no es nuevo en la historia de la
humanidad saben que hubo una época en la
que los seres humanos utilizábamos la
tracción a sangre andamos con carruajes
y caballos para movilizarnos y una época
que pensaron que las ciudades grandes se
van a quedar cubiertas de estiércol hay
un artículo famoso que publicó la
revista 'el times en londres
en 1894 prediciendo que en 50 años más
londres iba a quedar cubierta por 3
metros de estiércol
pero no terminó ahí porque después
cuando aparecieron los autos
también hubo un montón de detractores
decían que los autos era un juguete para
ricos que era un aparato vulgar y nocivo
que atropellaba niños y desbocaba
caballos
más recientemente se ha trabajando en la
industria de informática me tocó la
predicción de que se venía el año 2000 y
eso iba a ser muy malo para todos los
sistemas porque dirán ustedes porque la
mayoría de los programas que se habían
escrito en los primeros años del
software habían considerado solo dos
dígitos para los años y entonces cuando
llegara el primero de enero del año 2000
iban a creer que estábamos en el 1900 y
esto podía ser tremendamente
catastrófico porque si eso afectaba
algún sistema esencial podría provocarse
un efecto en cadena donde el mundo no
pudiera seguir más funcionando
recordaré yo que ese 31 de diciembre
de 1999 varios informáticos no estuvimos
celebrando la llegada del año 2000 sino
trabajando y haciendo horas de guardia
saben que a esta altura ya pensé pero la
humanidad ha superado muchas cosas este
pensamiento lineal y catastrófico no
necesariamente se da porque estamos
nosotros para hacer algo diferente pero
como si esto no fuera poco mirando los
datos del banco mundial descubrí que en
este momento de la humanidad tenemos la
mejor esperanza de vida que hubo nunca
en la historia de la humanidad nunca
hubo un porcentaje tan alto de la
población mundial que fuera que
accediera la alfabetización
la posibilidad de que nuestros hijos
sean afectados por la mortalidad
infantil disminuyó como nunca en la
historia de la humanidad las personas
que viven en pobreza extrema también se
redujeron en el mundo como nunca antes
el porcentaje de población que accede a
las comodidades de la clase media nunca
fue mayor
claro
a otra cosa hasta el agujero de ozono
escucharon que se empezó a reducir claro
no estoy diciendo que no hay más
problemas al contrario estoy
perfectamente consciente que en el año
2019 una muerte innecesaria o una
persona que vive en condiciones indignas
me hacen sentir muchísimo más culpable
pero luego de revisar estos datos estoy
segura que el futuro del trabajo va a
ser mejor de lo que nunca fue para los
seres humanos
aparecieron las tecnologías
exponenciales que ningún pensador
catastrófico jamás logro soñar que
tendríamos que son las tecnologías
exponenciales son estas tecnologías que
su costo disminuye permanentemente su
complejidad también disminuye pero a la
vez que aumenta su potencia su capacidad
su velocidad su uso y cada vez más
aplicaciones las utilizan estoy hablando
de la inteligencia artificial estoy
hablando del internet de las cosas estoy
hablando de la nanotecnología estoy
hablando de las impresiones 3d estoy
hablando de los drones
una cosa que seguramente no van a
olvidar ustedes porque cuando yo lo
escuché no lo pude olvidar más
los teléfonos inteligentes que hoy
tenemos en nuestras manos tienen más
capacidad computacional que la
computadora que llevo el apolo 11 a la
uv a la luna hace 50 años
según la gsm mobile económica es como
una asociación que que reúne a los
operadores de telefonía celular del
mundo la penetración de la telefonía
celular llega al 67 por ciento de la
población
se dan cuenta
tenemos una computadora que tiene el
potencial de alunizar en la luna en
nuestras manos
cada vez más estoy sintiendo que estamos
empoderados
pero además también está pasando algo
además de la tecnología exponencial
estamos frente a la información
exponencial estamos en una época que la
información se crea se disponibilizar y
se comparte en valores como nunca antes
ocurrió pero esto está generando que
mucha gente despierte conciencia no le
llama la atención la cantidad de
personas que después de haber visto
alguna información deciden no comer más
animales o personas que se comprometen
con el reciclaje o personas que deciden
no utilizar el más plástico en su vida o
personas que cambian la forma de
transportarse porque una vez que reciben
la información se despierta conciencia
y una vez que despiertas conciencia ya
no sos más el mismo
entonces estas personas que despiertan
su conciencia no quieren sumarse a
cualquier organización quieren estar en
organizaciones que encuentren ese
propósito y esos valores que tienen que
ver con sus vidas quieren relacionarse
con organizaciones que les permitan
alcanzar las motivaciones más profundas
los nativos digitales que ya nacieron en
un mundo inalámbrico y conectado muy
pronto serán la mayoría de la fuerza
laboral estos nativos digitales están
motivados por el bienestar cotidiano por
las experiencias significativas quieren
este ser sentirse ciudadanos del mundo
quieren los entornos colaborativas pero
además y fundamentalmente
se sienten empoderados por la tecnología
y estas personas
muchas veces se frustran porque no
encuentran en las organizaciones esos
líderes humildes esos líderes empáticos
esos líderes con capacidad de
escucharlos esos líderes con capacidad
de inspirarlos con sus palabras
y ellos estos jóvenes estas nuevas
generaciones descubrieron que no
necesita en el sistema
ellos se apropiaron de la tecnología y
se empoderaron con la tecnología y
entonces aparecieron estos hackers
podcasters youtubers instagramers
programadores de aplicaciones que no
necesitan trabajar en una organización
para alcanzar su propósito en la vida
algo más que está pasando en el mundo es
que las minorías no aceptamos más que no
se respeten nuestros derechos
pero también la cosa buena es que hay
varias organizaciones que se dieron
cuenta que para solucionar los problemas
complejos y ambiguos e inciertos que
enfrentamos hoy necesitamos de las
distintas visiones y perspectivas que
presenta un colectivo diverso además
como hay en las mayorías personas
conscientes también tenemos que ellos
mismos no quieren trabajar ni
relacionarse con organizaciones que nos
respeten a las minorías
estamos en la puerta de una humanidad
exponencial
debemos influenciar para que cambien los
sistemas educativos es fundamental que
salgamos de los problemas del modelo
educativo académico tradicional tenemos
que intentar que los estudiantes
trabajen con la innovación con la
observación con la reflexión
que tengan el optimismo de saber que
pueden resolver problemas concretos que
tiene la humanidad utilizando todas esas
tecnologías exponenciales que hablamos
como el internet de las cosas la
robótica la inteligencia artificial
los drones las impresiones 3d
debemos salir
en las organizaciones de modelos
jerárquicos
necesitamos que estas organizaciones
creen experiencias relevantes y
significativas aprovechando toda esa
tecnología exponencial pero sobre todo
toda la humanidad exponencial
solamente aquellas organizaciones que
logren combinar tecnología y humanidad
serán las capaces de retener al talento
y a los clientes
atraer y retener al talento y los
clientes y quienes no logren hacerlo
claramente van a desaparecer
yo pienso que quien escucha una charla
ted es un privilegiado
porque accede el conocimiento y acceder
al conocimiento es despertar conciencia
despertar conciencia es una gran
responsabilidad
tenemos el conocimiento el conocimiento
es poder el poder siempre estuvo en
manos de pocos
hoy el poder está en nuestras manos
yo siento que estamos empoderados y
todavía no lo reconocemos no nos damos
cuenta
podemos transformar lo que querramos del
mundo
podemos diseñar juntos el futuro del
trabajo exponencial
la meta de todos debería ser tener ser
tener una vida próspera y sostenible
encontrar tempranamente nuestro
propósito trabajar de lo que amamos ser
felices
tratando de generar esa autoconciencia
personas conscientes y empoderadas vamos
a diseñar el futuro del trabajo
[Aplausos]
[Música]